integration in extension to integration
extension to is just like integration in
extension one but you learn new
techniques right and so therefore you
take are you you sort of had this much
broader range of integrals that you can
then handle because you know how to do
more stuff it's like getting more tools
in your toolbox do you like cool I can I
can solve all problems now volumes are
much the same for unit volumes just like
three intuitive volumes but we learn new
ways with fancy cool new names that
allows us to tackle a wider range of
kinds of fellows okay so in order to
sort of introduce us into this let's
just start with what you already know
about volumes and I reckon excuse me
haters don't know let's uh let's write
down I reckon you can consolidate
everything you know about völva you
serve two three units into a single wine
what do you think it was me I'll start
you with this when two men volumes in
tina and three in it right we're not
talking about like the volume of a
rectangular prism or so like that with
email volumes in relation to integration
right what kinds of volumes do we tend
to think about come on guys T two and
three you learn about believes straight
after integration right what kinds of
volumes do you learn about you let that
solids of revolution don't shoot round
things right potter's wheel it goes
round and round and you get a shape okay
so because they're round things that's
why you start with uh okay right and
then what follows off to that
and enjoy usually the integral has some
kind of boundaries because you're
interested in a particular volume
what's the integrand it's y squared DX
and I suppose you could just as equally
say x squared dy and then you would be
well what would the difference be
different different axes so this is this
is horizontal axis right and if I did x
squared dy
it'd be the vertical axis there problems
okay my question to you right is what
does this actually mean why does this
like hi this is one of my favorites for
all sorts of equations to pull out to
confuse junior students when I say look
this is where you know if you do a
calculus course this is where it's going
your people like what is that is that
even Maps like there are no you know
what does it mean we went we've become
so good at that uh you can you just go
through the bushes and not actually
understand what it's talking about so
what is this thing what's it referring
to help you I want to think about it
like this okay if I gave you a function
he's a function right now we learn an
algebraic process right and we call it
differentiation which gives you this
result namely 2x good okay now this is
an algebraic process going from here to
here but geometrically it represents
something right it's not just our moving
numbers around and multiplied into
buying a tetra right geometrically what
does it mean what have you done what we
went from here to here what have you got
now you've got gradient don't you
gradient
glady is the geometric hmm meaning this
algebraic process is that make sense so
my question is the same here right
what's the geometric meaning of this
algebraic process I'm going to try and
break it down for you and hopefully it
will start to make a little sense no the
first thing I want to do is I'm going to
speak that PI inside because really he's
supposed to be inside there what do we
take him out just out of curiosity why
do we take the PI out because it's
constant and it doesn't actually affect
the process of integration right so
that's why we take him out but he really
actually called us from okay all right
great that's fine my next question is
what is this what is DX well you can
answer this in a variety of different
ways some better than others
what what's it what's a single answer
you could give me it's a people are
holding up please it's a it's a width
isn't it right it's the width of now
what's the width of who we actually
define DX DX is actually equal to not
just a width right it's actually an
infinitesimally small number and that's
what the DS are that's a slight change
in X horizontally okay so in terms of
limits we can say this like this
right think about this right I'll go
back to first principles first principle
says this can you recite it for me age
pressure zero of FX plus h minus f of X
all over H ok look look dy right rise
that's this thing as you take the limit
as H approaches zero right that's do you
want
well DX is this bit down the bottom it's
H as H approaches zero okay that's this
small ever-increasing thing okay so let
me try and take that and bring that into
here okay I'm gonna write it like so if
I go back to this limit notation I can't
use an integral anymore okay what I
really mean is it's a sum of a bunch of
things right I'm gonna go from this sum
these boundaries here even though we
didn't have any variable attached to
them we assumed the X variables right
because we're either respect to X right
so I go from x equals a to b I'm gonna
add up all of these things what am i
adding up and adding and it's H but with
a limit on it
that's a bit weird and it's a little
hard to see as well so what I'm going to
do is if you add up a series of things
and this thing is getting increasingly
smaller okay I can think about this
limit at the front right just like the
limit of this over this is the limit of
the whole thing
so why should write the limit notation
at the beginning like so okay now have
we done enough twisting and turning that
the geometric meaning of this algebraic
process is clear what is this shape we
know what this shape is this is a
cylinder right because these are
dimensions all we need to do is to say
you know let's call this ah there you go
there's my cylinder okay so what we're
saying is how did we get this volume
what was the geometric meaning the
geometric meaning is what we've got is
an infinite number of infinitesimally
thin cylinders and cylinders are 3d
shapes they have a volume and so if you
put them all together you get the total
does that make sense okay now here's the
thing let's actually draw one because
help us to understand what's going on
okay
why don't we draw for instance from
let's do X square plus 1 what's that
look like
we'll just do it on the first coin okay
there's X square plus one now if I
rotate this around the x-axis that's
true Civ boundaries as well let's go
from zero to four something like that
will do okay now if I'm going around the
x axis this is the kind of shape I'm
going to get
okay right now where is this in here
where is it well there's an infinite
number of them right so I don't really
wanna draw all of them because then
they'll sort of cloud each other but if
I just take that one
just take one different like this there
you go
there's a cylinder in there right that
radius the radius their radius of this
cylinder looking at sideways okay it's
radius is x squared plus one wherever X
is okay so it's radius is why that's why
you've got PI Y squared there rather
than PI R squared okay
I suppose we should then you say oh it's
just a function of X okay where's H H is
this that's why you're doing that with
your fingers right that's that tiny
little width it okay now is this
cylinder okay how do we get this
cylinder and what do the rest of the
cylinders look like okay um I actually
showed you a model of this before right
if I drew all the rest of them the
effect is kind of like turning this Sun
this weird kind of parabola shape
turning into like salami
right we're cutting it up into lots of
well when you got lots of salami or ham
or any other kind of food you get from a
deli what do you call it a slice that's
what we're doing isn't it we're cutting
this we're slicing it importantly and
this isn't this is vital for you to
write down we are forming slices or
we're slicing across this volume a
circular volume but in order to get
cylinders now all right
which way do you slice it cuz you can
slice things in lots of different ways
right we are slicing in a very
particular way
how could you describe the direction
hmm it's gonna have to do with the axis
of rotation right because don't draw
this one but if I had rotated the other
way
there's x-squared gone this way in order
to gate get those same cylindrical
slices I'm not going to cut that way
right I'm gonna cut this way and then
you would get a slice like suck okay so
I think I heard it right we are slicing
across the volume perpendicular to and
it's the axis of rotation that we can
refer to in this case it was the x axis
which is why your slices line up along
the y axis parallel to the last